she is a well she was formerly
used to be a pole vaulter
and she claims that she could still pull
off a few pull-ups with her kids hanging
on to her
so i think that's a challenge accepted
you need to do that
please everyone welcome to the stage
major maxine
and i i told jared that i would be happy
to to show the pull-ups but i'm in
uniform so it'd be impractical
so that's my excuse i am major maxine
drake
i am coming to you to talk about my
lessons learned my personal lessons
learned from
the uh one of the army's coven 19
uh models projection models now this is
not
the official army model this is
one projection model of a few that we
have in the army
that is a large scale and it has
informed the senior most army leaders
today i will uh first i'll tell you who
i am uh
go over a personal introduction i will
discuss our
model briefly describe to you what it is
and then
uh go over some coding lessons learned
that i hope will be of some use to
someone in the audience and
finally i'll discuss some project
management and team management
observations i've made over the course
of this project
i am like i said active duty i am an
operations researcher that is my career
field in the army
as an operations researcher i am serving
as a data analyst for the center for
army analysis
here at fort belvoir virginia uh before
being uh what we call an orsa
analyst i was an engineer officer so i
served
as an engineer officer as a platoon
leader an executive officer
a company commander all in combat
engineer units
i've served it in north carolina
louisiana
and afghanistan i went to west point
united states military academy and
graduated in 2009
with a bachelor's in economics in
russian
later on i went to george mason
university
and got my masters in operations
research
that is where i started using r so in
around 2017 is when i started
our our model so i'm going to summarize
it briefly but first
i didn't mention this is an i o slide
presentation and i'll give a quick shout
out to mallory
uh who really sold it last time when she
gave her presentation
using a dashboard and inspired me to use
ios
use r to generate i o slides and
dashboards
our model like i said its purpose is to
project covid cases estimate future
covid cases
and um at its core it is a seer model
a seer stands for susceptible exposed
infected and removed it is a standard
epidemiological model
and it's what epidemiologists call a
compartmental model which means
the entirety of a population that you're
modeling falls into one of
in this case four bins first
uh individuals are in the susceptible
bin which means they're vulnerable have
never been contacted the virus then
those then individuals move into the e
bin which is exposed that means
they come into contact and they're
incubating the virus
and then individuals move into the
infected bin which is
um the they are individuals are actively
infectious
or contagious and um whether or not
they're symptomatic
and then finally they move into the
u-bin which
which is what we call the removed bin um
which means individuals are immune to
the disease and or virus
and no longer susceptible of course
there are a lot of assumptions here i'm
not going to really
talk about those because that that would
take a long time
um i do want to touch on a couple other
things about the model which is
we have uh what i would describe as a
sub model it's our primary sub model
which
is an xg boost model that estimates
future
r naught values are not being the basic
reproductive rate
of coven of the coronavirus
um we trained the model on several data
sets
include about 30 different variables
from data sets including
population mobility uh state policy
population demographics and of course
covet 19
case trends we have a couple other
smaller scale
sub models or calculations that we use
to
update parameter values and initial
values
for the model each day that we run it
we run this model for every county in
the united states
and we run it again for every county and
core based statistical area which is
effectively a group of counties
so i'll talk to you about some coding
lessons learned if you're a programmer
out there bear with me
you are aware of my academic experience
and i have not been i did not learn r
through a programming lens so some of
this might not
be relevant to you however i'm hoping
that there's someone
out there like me one year ago who
um didn't fully realize certain
uh benefits to what i'm about to talk
about function
and then later on some new packages that
i learned
um so function i realize function is old
news uh so i'm not here to
talk about what function is and how to
use it but i do want to talk about
the benefits of using function and
modularizing code
that i didn't fully recognize like i
said one year ago
so our model began as
one script one long run on script is how
i would describe it
um the uh what we did was we modularized
the first thing we did is we modularized
the code so we organized it into
purpose-specific or task-specific chunks
and and then translated those chunks
into functions
so each function has a specific task and
at the end i'll highlight
and what i show here are our functions
you can't see what goes on in the
functions but you can
sort of get a gist of each one of these
has a task the first one
uh not surprisingly downloads daily data
as the title suggests
or the name suggests the last one i'll
highlight is called seromodular and i'll
talk about this one later on
this is our wrapper function and this is
where we set all the default argument
values
that we want the model to use most
frequently
and it dictates the sequence of those
preceding functions that we want the
model to be routed through
so more on function because i have
i have a a new love for this uh
capability
um so first of all functions allow us to
expand our mental model and by that i
mean
in the beginning when we had one long
run on script we had to
conceptualize the entire script all at
once the whole model all at once
once we modularized it and turned it
into tasks
specific functions we really just had to
conceptualize
one task or one function at a time
which allowed us to make the model
larger
and more complex
second it made our model more flexible
so instead of hard-coding values
into our script we could now um
use arguments to define to and run the
function using arguments
um using whatever parameter values or
coefficient values that we wanted
when we ran that when we run the
function so take this one step further
and
instead of changing a parameter an
argument value from
say 4 to 7 we can also change it from
4 to a vector or a list of values
which made solving the solving these
functions or
executing these functions iteratively
possible
it also made
performing these functions in parallel
possible as well
using the fur package which i'll touch
on in a moment
um we were able to replace entire
functions
sort of like swapping a car part so if
the structure of the input
was the same and the structure of the
output what came out of the function was
the same
then it didn't matter what happened
inside the function
so uh we could generate an entirely new
function
if we were developing the model with
some new capability
and then when we were ready we flipped
the switch and we told our wrapper
function
use function a instead of function b or
vice versa
uh what we did was we took our core
scripts a couple of our core scripts and
we made them entirely comprised
of functions and then we sourced these
scripts
um this and this was good practice
uh what i learned is it was good
practice for a couple different reasons
first uh is that we were made we were
going into those core scripts less
often because whenever we had to um
go into model development or run or run
the model or
uh troubleshoot we didn't need to do it
in that core script anymore we just
needed to source that core script and
run those functions elsewhere
so it meant fewer changes to those core
scripts which made
merging in git a lot simpler
the second reason this uh making these
sourceable scripts
was good practice was that it allowed us
to use
these functions uh in other areas of our
analysis
so now we were able to do validation and
verification by using those
core model running scripts and but for a
completely different purpose
and then finally i can't go on without
saying that we are um our objective is
to make a package
uh we're in the preliminary steps but we
uh
we need a bit more bandwidth to to
finish that
so a couple packages one of course tidy
verse i'm not going to talk about tidy
verse because i'm comfortable
i'm sure we are all comfortable with the
role tigers plays in our coding
um and if and if it's new to you please
look it up um
the what i will talk about is fur so fur
is uh
allows one to execute a function
um in parallel over over multiple cores
on your uh computer
uh so what i've done here is i'm going
to take you through just a
very simple sequence of uh how to
how a simple function gets translated
into a fur function
so the first example here is and i'll go
ahead and show
all of them um the first function
here uh is we're running
that wrapper function i mentioned
earlier sir modular and
i i'm running it in this first chunk
using
one singular fips a fips is uh in this
case
a county code and one singular date
um this is the simplest way to run a
function we're running the model with
uh with these two inputs arguments
the second chunk uh runs the seer
modular model
no i can't talk right now please get out
thank you
mike as you can see i'm teleworking so
my kids don't
appreciate that much
anyways um so the next example is the
per so we're running
seer modular over a vector of fips and a
vector of dates
this performs performance per performs
the executes
serial modular iteratively um similar to
a for loop but it's a
little cleaner i'd say than a for loop
then the last chunk
is translating that into fur so
just like before we're solving it
solving serial modular over a vector of
fips and a vector of dates
we set a plan so we tell
for how many chords we want to perform
that execute the functions
over and then we use uh fur to execute
seromodular and it's a simple
translation from per if you're
comfortable with per all you have to do
is uh almost all you have to do is uh
add future at the beginning of the
function and it's
it's a simple translation
so for um because it's working in
parallel rather than iteratively
it is a lot faster and uh i
ran one chunk of our model
using four different functions one was
fur using eight cores on my laptop
and it was the future imap dfr function
i also used per imac dfr
l apply and a for loop you can see the
the latter three
are almost took very close to the same
amount of time per was slightly faster
but fur was just significantly faster
yes less than half the time to
when using uh eight cores
so i talked about the technical
highlights um
from our from our code and our model but
i also want to touch on what i hope will
be interesting to this audience which is
um some observations i
had of our management uh in
communi in organizing and communicating
our our analysis
and managing uh our team uh i'll use a
couple different
terms so there are a couple groups of
people i'm i'm gonna refer to one is
our management and that is um
our boss effectively we had a couple
different people who are leading our
team
who organized our analysis who gave us
direction
uh us being the modeling team um and
then
communicated that and briefed that to
senior leaders
senior leaders are the other group i'm
going to talk about senior leaders are
those whom we support informed
uh they were our customer if you will
and those are the the senior leaders
of the army they include the vice chief
of staff the head of
operations and planning for the army and
um
so i just don't want to get confused on
those two groups that i'm about to talk
about
the way i would characterize our
management's approach to
uh informing the senior leaders
was attend their attentiveness to the
senior leaders decision cycle
so first was a willingness to
a willingness to defer improvements in
precision
the way i would describe that is a late
answer to a problem
is a non-answer to a problem and i'm
sure that's not
just true in the army but i can really
only speak for my experience in the army
so under duress by that i mean under
duress senior leaders will always prefer
less less precise information to no
information at all
this is difficult for us analysts to
accept
because we always want our work to be as
precise and accurate as possible
um so there's a book but there's a
trade-off and this is what our
management
um really thought hard about is the
trade-off between
timeliness for the sake of meeting a
decision maker's timeline
and precision
because that is our one of our goals as
analysts
and they were able to understanding the
model
and our analysis as well as the senior
leaders decision environment
allowed them to make informed decisions
um
and weigh those trade those competing
priorities effectively
second eagerness to anticipate likely
questions
so generally speaking what i've noticed
is by the time the decision maker knows
what he or she needs
to make decisions or make a specific
decision
there may not be enough time to develop
the informative
and actionable analytics or in our case
to
develop the model accordingly so
our team management accepted some risk
in developing and
executing analytics before an official
tasking or question came down
so basically this meant we could answer
questions faster
for for me and the rest of the modeling
team uh there were about
three or three or four of us uh in the
on the modeling team at any point in
time
um for us this meant we were constantly
in
development mode and production mode at
the same time
remember so okay so remember how i said
when we modularized the code we were
able to swap functions like car parts
this ended up being very useful because
we had our production model
and um and we were able to develop
functions that would replace a specific
task
function and then tell the wrapper
function to route
the model and flip that switch route the
model through this new
function that we had developed um of
course we also used git to
you know create new branches in when
when developing but
this was ended up being a pretty handy
uh way of keeping the model flexible
um third was
the attentiveness to uh the actual
requirements of the decision maker
and so what i mean by this is
decision makers often do not need
complex and nuanced
solutions to their problems what they
need
is concise and focused and actionable
and explainable results
provided within their decision cycles
before i mention the trade-off between
timeliness
and precision well there's also the
trade-off uh that my management
sort of helped me understand which is uh
the trade-off between precision and
simplicity
simplicity for the sake of the consumer
so the best answer to a decision maker
is not necessarily the most precise one
often
it's the answer that of course is
precise don't get me wrong
but it's also understandable too
um and that is the last point i had to
make um
so at this point i'd just like to thank
you all
uh for you know letting me speak and
your attention
and i'd be happy to talk during the the
social
room periods that we have
thank you major maxine it's always great
having a service member speak at our
conferences
so our next speaker is me